legendary actress Glenda Jackson could
soon make Tony Award history the 82 year
old is already one of two dozen people
who have earned the Triple Crown of
acting with two Oscars two Emmys and a
Tony tomorrow she's expected to earn
another Tony nomination for her
gender-bending performance as King Lear
on Broadway if she wins she would be the
first to win Best Actress in
back-to-back years she talked to us
about her role in King Lear and much
more you said Shakespeare really asks
three questions absolutely who are we
what are we why are we and no one's come
up with sufficiently comprehensive
answers so I suppose we lord keep on
asking those questions
they're the questions Glenda Jackson
takes on as King Lear in this new
adaptation of the Shakespearean tragedy
on Broadway doggedly the case in
Shakespeare you often learn more about
your own character what other people say
or do then what he actually gives you to
say but that's life isn't it god the guy
was genius go back to the moment you're
told you're going to play Lear what is
the first set of things you do the first
set of things I did was to find out the
hours that elderly people could use the
pools in my local swimming pool because
I was really scared that I didn't have
either the physical or the vocal
strength for it and so I would get in
the pool with my fellow elderly women
and it was really marvelous it was like
a kind of elderly United Nations just I
mean there were always swimming and
walking and it was great there is an
energy in these plays and if you manage
to tap into that it just carries you
along like a kind of jet plane or
something and if that is extraordinary
and very unique and her performance as
Lear is extraordinary eight times a week
a three and a half hour show she roars
and stomps across the stage
it's a reminder of the Jackson we knew
in love from the 1960s to the 90s
Jackson received two Oscars for Best
Actress for women in love charming and a
touch of class you are all the same this
obsession with male sexual prowess she
won audiences and two Emmys as Queen
Elizabeth the first in the PBS
masterpiece Elizabeth are you never had
nor shall have any who loves you better
but after decades of captivating
performances she retired from acting in
1992 people to become a politician when
the jaxa she served as a member of
parliament in the UK for 23 years what
roles are being written for women in
politics I think there has been a major
shift there there's a basic basic date
that yet has to be opened women can not
like each other
I mean actively positively dislike each
other but they can't sit around a table
and concentrate on a problem that
requires solution and come up with the
solutions everything after a long hiatus
from acting Jackson reemerged on
Broadway last year in three tall women
we need yet another reward thank you
very much indeed
this time Tony I feel blessed in as much
as the the socio-economic group I come
from it was very simple if you didn't
work you didn't eat and so I have been
blessed with a strong work ethic and I
value that very much you know
interviewers will say about the play is
it fun are you enjoying it that my
immediate responses it's work 20 a main
it's work any when I think of all those
years that they pursued work and didn't
get it you mentioned how playwrights are
not writing roles for women what do we
think that is I don't know it still
remains that if a woman is successful
whatever she chooses to do she is the
exception proves the rule
if she fails well we told you they were
all failures and that basic untruth I
don't see fracturing or cracking or
becoming frayed around the edges as far
as contemporary dramatists it concerned
and it puzzles me I don't know why they
find it so boring have you ever thought
about writing well I couldn't write a
postcard I swear to you I couldn't why I
don't know I like to think my brain
moves too quickly and my hand can't
catch up but I'm sure that isn't true
because when I have said that people say
to me well then record it and I said
then I'd be talking to myself and we all
know what that's the first sign oh she
turns 83 next week but for Jackson she
says age is more of an annoyance than
anything else the me inside hasn't
changed at all I mean I think the me
inside he's about 15 years old
it's the envelope that's carrying the me
inside around that simply refuses to do
what I tell it no I mean I think is
won't work and you know my back is me
trouble and I lose my balance and things
like that and also also I so we're of
how much I don't know and I think my god
Jason
have you got time to learn laughter wait
and see
she's so wise oh so wise and and she
talks about even as much theater as
she's done before every performance it
feels as though this might be the time I
can't do it which is to say that she has
that aliveness with every single
performance and Lear is a is a heck of a
show I mean that's a big performance you
have to put a lot into that every night
yeah and she says if by the end you're
not totally spent yeah and totally wrung
out then you haven't done your job not
easy to do it eighty-three is she says
it is work right well she points out if
they're not going to write plays for
women then women will just play men yeah
she's beginning a trend it's like being
in the presence of an energy transformer
being near her she's amazing she's a lot
going on and we'll bring you tomorrow we
will bring you the Tony nominations
right here on CBS this morning Gail will
be on stage with two of Broadway's
biggest stars to announce the nominees
and on June 9th at 73rd annual Tony
Awards will be hosted by the late shows
James Corden you can watch right here on
CBS